alright guys welcome back to L fame the
very last time lapse video although not
the last video of L fame and hopefully
also not the last video of L fame today
today I'm gonna work on well in this
video I should probably say in this
video I'm gonna work on the path
elements and what I want to actually do
with these time lapses is that even
though this is just a fraction of what
I'll be doing to finish this ride I
didn't want to give a good impression of
like the general things that I did to
finish it so like most of the things
that I have done will be featured in
this video just not all of it so like
I'm making fences over here except I
this time-lapse doesn't show the making
of all of the fences all over the park
but this is more or less like the
approach that I took with it and making
fences and path elements is one of the
things I wanted to get in here I also
wanted to get into the scenery around
the roller-coaster itself just for space
reasons I didn't want to get into making
large buildings for the coasters to go
through or interact with there is just
barely any space to do that kind of idea
and I wanted to actually keep much of
this area quite open since I have a
couple of sight lines that I really want
to preserve but you know some some
general theming to make it a bit more
interesting than just empty rocks and
foliage so as you can see the kind of
thing that I wanted to get into is some
steps and stairs and wooden catwalks and
supports all sorts of things that can
pretty much be built around and
underneath and interacting with the
coaster kind of scenery and that is
basically what I'll be going for for
quite a bit here if you might actually
remember the old roller coaster [ __ ]
three times there's a coaster recalled
on Potter which is well my favorite
roller coaster tycoon 3 coaster what
second-favorite I should say of all time
it's a really amazing coaster and it has
a lot of amazing interaction with
catwalks and all sorts of wooden scenery
on the ground and it's that kind of idea
which I want to go for a bit in here as
well but there's also some other coaster
scenery interaction one really
interesting thing is actually some
waterfalls underneath the coaster tracks
which I'll get to later in this video
and talk about how and why I wanted to
do it as well now one of the other
things that I also wanted to get into is
some different vents designs like
obviously I wanted to get the offense
design in with the drift with blanks
since they're just really useful to make
different things out of I also wanted to
get a fence design which is quite
similar actually to the fences around
nemesis in Alton Towers just kind of
like the the ironwork fences that are
designed to keep you out of the parts
where the coaster track goes but with a
more wooden Elvidge each look to it and
that's the idea behind this I mean
generally there's an important reason
why you would see fences like this in
real life and when you see them around
nemesis like if I didn't have these
fences around here people would very
easily just be able to walk onto the
track or the area where the track goes
and since the track comes really close
to the paths here but also because there
are many tips and valleys which you can
fall into like this this valley over
here with the junior Immelman elements
it's just really dangerous to have your
people go around everywhere and that's
why realistically I wanted to add some
safety elements like defences around
here so in a way defenses have kind of a
double function since they're for one
just a realistic safety function but
they also just make the area look a bit
nicer they're a part of the scenery as
well and that's why I wanted to make
them look like this and not just go with
very simple ironwork fences or something
that kind of breaks the theme it's one
of these things also where I guess this
coaster kind of drifts between fantasy
and reality since you know this the
scenery over here is just way too
expensive for real theme park C to ever
decide to put that much money into just
two dueling coasters on such a large
amount of area but on the other hand I
didn't want to like keep some rules of
well a degree of realism to this aside
from all the elven magic that allows me
to go for the ridiculous theming at some
points and so I did still want to add
like some safety measures the coaster
layouts in general
would say are pretty realistic except
maybe for the lack of mid course breaker
on which you would kind of like to see
Anna coaster with this length and the
fact that there are Java NOLA inverts
and Java no law doesn't even exist
anymore but now in general I wanted to
keep some theme park rules and keep some
rules of realism in here well at the
same time just pretty much giving myself
a wild card with the scenery to kind of
you know do more ridiculous things than
I would normally do when I try to keep
it realistic and trying to keep many
things smaller less all over the place
then I would normally do setting goes
for foliage - actually the foliage is
kind of unrealistic in the sense that
it's very varied as a sort of idea I
think that many people have is that
foliage is the best when it's like
really abundant really varied with as
much of different colors and shrubs as
you can find but from a realism
standpoint I would normally actually
like to avoid that especially when it
comes to flowers you can see me adding
flowers just about every corner of the
roller-coaster in this case but in
realistic cases I would kind of say it's
better to avoid doing it since in the
end some workers of the park are gonna
have to flower all of those flowers and
they're gonna have to be planted and
cared for so you normally just find
flower beds and very close to the path
and very maintainable areas but over
here I kind of just wanted to go a bit
more interesting with the foliage as
well and pretty much the only thing that
I wanted to do with the foliage is make
it look as cool as inter and interesting
as possible and why I wanted to keep it
quite realistic so no enormous elven
trees or anything like that I do feel
that kind of adds to the magical feeling
of the entire valley to have many
flowers and very varied and dense
foliage around the ride in the end one
of the ideas that I kind of feel the
ride carries is the sort of elven
village in the middle of the forest
that's kind of hidden you don't really
see it from the general surrounding well
except for the castle that is but it's
like a kind of hidden elven village that
you know doesn't just
exist within the forest but it kind of
you know kind of moves with the forest
if that makes any sense it's kind of
part of the forest almost and that's why
I wanted to have like really dense
foliage around this part and also have
very dense foliage around all of the
houses that I have as well as you know
the many hanging baskets and flower
boxes and planters that I have around
the buildings as well and I'm moving on
to some different detail which also very
much provides a safety function while at
the same time being interesting part of
scenery when you often see in real life
coasters underneath tracks as they pass
over paths is a coaster nuts
to just avoid people from dropping
things out of the coaster onto the path
below the coaster and potentially onto
people's heads so it's a very common
safety feature and it's something that I
well can't really have in here since
coaster nets
Oren's part of the game at least I've
seen them on the lift hill but not
actually whenever they'll pass over
parts would actually be a really
interesting feature in the game now when
I come to think of it but um I wanted to
have something similar over here since
the coaster pulses like really straight
over the path here I figured it would be
quite nice to add a coaster net-like
function with that wooden overhang over
the path and it also makes the
interaction between mid path and the
track a little bit more interesting I
think
now speaking of interesting things this
is one of my favorite parts of the ride
in the end even though it's a really
simple feature and I didn't even really
come up with it over here I wanted to
have like a really interesting dive into
this drop here because these drops for
both coasters are in to the deepest
point of the roller coaster or at least
the fastest point of the roller coaster
and they are going into the looping
which is like you know it signifies the
halfway points of both coasters and I
think it's just the most visible and
interesting parts of the layout of these
coasters where they and I kind of goes
go into the deepest fastest part of the
layouts and split ways after that so I
wanted to make the scenery over here a
bit unique
I thought in a sense in the end it's not
that unique but like a very interesting
dip into this very deep dive
underneath the path now what you might
know if you know nemesis in Alton Towers
is that nemesis at least used to have
blood waterfalls running underneath its
tracks and as you dip into like the very
deep valleys of nemesis there is the
stream of blood that's just you know for
instance way underneath the track and
that you really fly over very closely
and it's that kind of idea which I
actually wanted to try over here as well
except for blood waterfalls I'm just
choosing for regular water waterfalls
because this is you know an elephant
village in the end you want to keep it a
little bit children friendly and a
little bit nice as well so some water
waterfalls
besides there is not even blood in the
game yet or there's not even blood I'm
not sure if they're really gonna add
blood waterfalls to the game I mean it's
not really the most commonly requested
feature but um yeah I wanted to have
some waterfalls underneath the tracks
here just to provide like an interesting
thing underneath you as you dive into
this drop which is really fast and into
these 30 points in the layouts and I
figured the water via thanks would work
quite nicely for it it's also very nice
since I didn't really work with the vs
VFX a lot on to this point actually I
didn't work with the VFX at all so I
figured it would be nice to try those
effects a little bit I'm saying video
effects but they're just effects think
pretty sure no they call it VFX right
we're going with VFX in that case but I
wanted to mess around with that a little
bit as well and figure this would be a
good opportunity to do so and I was a
bit skeptical at first figuring that
they are just water fountains and
they're supposed to be used for
fountains and they don't really have a
lot of water coming out of it and I
wasn't really sure how good it would
look as a flowing waterfall but adding
quite a few ads like similar places but
switching up the location and the
rotation of all the difference water
sprinklers here it's just a little bit
to make it look like one very big wall
of water works pretty well to create the
idea of a waterfall and after that I
just used the rocks to get rid of the
pieces that don't look so good where
it's really clear that these artists
you know actual fountains and make sure
that the waterfalls feel more like
they're falling over the rocks instead
of just being waterfalls behind these
rocks like make sure that they're kind
of worked into the rocks a little bit
more and a little bit nicer and so
that's the idea new idea behind placing
these rocks I wanted to place the well
I'm not really sure what to call it but
I wanted to place the Shuar like
entrance at the end at the top of these
waterfalls just to make it look as if
there is some sort of draining thing
where the water is coming out and at the
bottom I'll be playing I'll be placing
some wooden planks at the very bottom of
this valley to make it also look as if
the water at the end kind of escapes
between the rocks that kind of idea and
make sure that actually looks like it's
going somewhere and I am quite happy
actually with how it turned out in the
end
definitely quite positively surprised
with how well these things actually work
as waterfalls it takes a lot of time to
get their exact position right and make
sure that everything around it works
quite nicely to this idea it's very easy
to end up with waterfalls that like look
very clearly fake and very clearly like
they're just water fountains and try to
avoid that that as much as I could here
and quite happy with the final result
now moving over to the very final part
of this video which I won't completely
be finishing because I stopped recording
here for some reason
and in hindsight I'm not even entirely
sure why I did so I will be finishing
these at some point in the future but
there is just no way that I am still
gonna record that that would just be way
too much of a time stress to get the
time-lapse video out in time before I'm
going to release the final video so this
is the last bit of time-lapse that
you'll see of the park I was basically
still planning to have a facade over
here and the beginning of the making of
that facade is seen over here and
something which I didn't do before but
figured would be quite nice to actually
use as a bit of the kids to save some
time here is to just take an existing
building as a template take the roof
from that since the roofs of many of the
buildings are quite similar and like the
distinction in the buildings is mostly
in the different details that I used
pillars and windows and the general
shape of the building so I just took a
roof and a few pillars from an existing
building it's just a save a bit of time
and make my life a bit easier here and
that is gonna serve as the base for the
new building over here albeit with
different details and on the side of
this building I'll have three different
facades and they're all just gonna
connect into this one big sort of Main
Street like building that I wanted to
get in here just to make this side of
the park look a little bit more like an
elven village as well and also to
actually get some functionality into
this part because at the moment there
are no toilets or anything of that sort
of thing so I wanted to get some toilets
in and this is just a good opportunity
to actually get some functionality into
this Park and actually allow the people
of the park to go to the toilets which
is pretty nice and pretty crucial
feature so there it goes which is gonna
sit in the building which is gonna be
right next to this building though so
yeah even though I won't finish this
facade in this video you'll be able to
see everything that I've made for this
place and the rest of the park which I
won't be filming a lot of what-what I
won't be filming is a lot of foliage
work a lot of just placing trees and all
these hills it's not that interesting I
think it's just you know in general
finishing the final touches of the park
and making sure that it's not located in
this very big empty grassy Greenland
there are also some other things that
I'll get into like making the queues
look nicer adding some extra detail
actually to like some of the other parts
of the park which I haven't focused on
so much like the entrance part or the
parts around the queue or the flat ride
that I've had for quite a while already
and also just adding some final touches
and tweaks to the existing things in the
park which doesn't really translate that
well into time-lapse anyway and it's
more or less that's everything that
you're gonna miss with me not recording
the final parts of making all of this
now with that out of the way there were
a couple of things that I kind of want
to talk about a little bit because I
haven't actually talked much about the
competition that I am
making this for basically it's
competition from from seeing themselves
it's not that special it's just a
competition for the best video and
you'll be there will be your like votes
and the jury on what's gonna be the best
video and there is no real objective way
to find out about it and I'm basically
more or less in it for the prize which
is really cool it's a meet and greet
with the frontier staff in Cambridge
like a paid dinner there's also a
foundation stone which for some reason
they put first but I'm not really sure
if I'm really that interested in it but
yeah it's really awesome price which is
why I'm giving it a try but I've seen so
many comments that I'm gonna win this
contest for sure and I kind of want to
speak up against that because I'm
actually not expecting myself to win and
I'm not trying to say that just to be
humble I'm well trying to say that
because I'm really not expecting myself
to win and I don't want to get all
pissed when I don't end up winning
because just in general it's a contest
for one it's just not objective anyone
can really win and it's a lot about the
creativity and you know what kind of new
things are original things you're
bringing to it as well
there's also just the fact that there's
already this idea in general that I'm a
favorite and I see a lot of people
saying that and I think what actually
makes the contest such such an
opportunity is that they're probably I
think rolling this contest to find some
creators who don't get as much of a
spotlight who make amazing things but
just aren't as well known for it
like if you've read the rules they can
actually use the footage from the
contest entries for any promotional ways
that they want to so they're probably
just looking in general to for you know
a good way to find out what the
community makes without having to go on
big hunts for actually what people make
and I think in that way it would also be
cool if the contest ends up you know
bringing forward some of the people who
aren't as well known but still make some
really amazing creations and make this
more of a contest about just the things
that are made rather than the people who
were entering it anyway we'll all see
who is gonna win the contest and how
this project ends up I'm gonna release
the final cinematic video later today
and at some point in the future I think
the results are going to be known one
week after the deadline okay I'll let
you guys know how I did in the contest
and whether I want it or not so thank
you guys watching this so far and I hope
you guys stick around for the final
cinematic POV video